a moment of celebration for another
supporters the Conservative Party has
secured 46 seats in preliminary results
but it's a bitter victory for a party
that won 69 seats five years ago we are
at the beginning of a new period the
people have given us their trust and we
will live up to it we will use all of
Tunisia's political capital in order to
achieve the main objectives of the
revolution such as a protection of
personal and public freedoms the second
objective is dignity which requires jobs
education health services the secular
heart of Tunisia has come in second with
35 seats the party was founded three
months ago by media tycoon Nabil car.we
who's in jail on corruption charges the
coalition of dignity and alliance of
independent candidates came in third
with twenty seats and a surprising
performance by the newcomer the
Constitutional Liberal Party securing 16
seats the party was established in 2013
by a beer moosie a lawyer and loyalist
of the forum of President Zine El
Abidine Ben Ali but the Biggest Loser is
near Tunis or the core of Tunisia the
party of former president Beji Caid
Essebsi which was the largest party in
2014 with 86 seats in parliament it was
an election marred by growing discontent
with the political establishment a few
voters showed up at this polling station
in the capital Tunis most of them
elderly but determined to be part of
Tunisia second democratic election since
the revolution 8 years ago many
Tunisians are angry with their leaders I
very much wanted to see young candidates
unfortunately it's the same old elite
security and economy should be the top
priority for the government during the
campaign another and the heart of
Tunisia brushed aside joining a
coalition government if another phase
so form an alliance within 60 days the
president can call for new elections
there is a feeling of anxiety about what
may happen next if another in the heart
of Tunisia set aside their differences
that may guarantee stability in a
country beset by economic problems but
the two have been trading accusations
over the past few weeks raising fears of
a prolonged political impasse - bara
al-jazeera - this